He's gone to Cuba in the worst way >> I wonder who owns
the New York Post and what political leanings they MIGHT HAVE.
>> CHLEPE, NO! CHLEPE, DON'T GO TO RUPERT MURDOCH'S EARLY
LIFE ARTICLE. THAT'S THE WAY YOU LOSE YOUR YOUTUBE ACCOUNT. CHLEPE,
STOP! >> Look at how disgusting this guy is, like larping
as a poor person. Look at how gross he is.
>> Oh, yeah, let's do let's let's stop the Chlepe video
real quick.
Cuz it's going to be Hasan Cuba stuff. Chlepe did a video, okay?
Chlepe did a video on
More Pegasar, okay?
At the end of the year >> This guy sucks, this Pegasus
guy, okay? He
In 2024, the American people had a decision to make and they
decided to vote for Donald Trump. They decided that the person
to lead them into the next half of the decade was the orange
man with despicable hair and a weird history of probably kids.
In large part, what I believe has always shaped this has been
that the MAGA voter is simply dumber, >> I don't think
he's Indian. I get what you're saying though. There's like a
This is like the guy Indian people use AI to make themselves
look like, where it's like there's some element there that you
could believe, but he's not. I think he's like Middle Eastern
or something ethnically.
He's got to have Dude, he's Canadian. He's got to have some like
uh some Native American indigenous in there. It's got to be a
little bit, >> it more stupid >> That guy >> And
and unfortunately, this makes them an easy target for manipulation.
The people that saw hundreds of photos of Donald Trump hanging
out with Jeffrey Epstein thought that Donald Trump was the chosen
one to expose the That same Donald Trump, by the way, who was
forced to pay $80 million for someone he defamed and assaulted.
You like affordability? Gas prices are everyone in the ass right
now. You guys remember the no new war slogan? Yeah, do you guys
know what's going on here? It has something to do with those
gas prices. But hey, as long as Israel is getting what it wants,
you Americans are fine with it, right? But hey, speaking of foreign
actors influencing the American sentiment, let's take a look
at Pegasus. Pegasus, like Tectone, like Asmongold, like every
other conservative streamer has realized, hey, there's a lot
of money to be made off these conservative Look at that. In his
last nine videos, eight of them are on I I sincerely wish to
the to the bottom of bottom of my soul that it was just conservatives
who consume this content. I wish it was just conservatives, okay?
That would make my life so much easier.
Unfortunately, there's a significant
liberal bend to a ton of this stuff, where liberals love this
content so much. It sucks,
okay? >> on Hasan. Are you guys you guys happy? You guys
happy? Oh, the socialist, he's owning the libs. He's owning the
socialists. By the way, this guy lives on the other side of the
planet and is farming you guys for ad revenue. Now, something
I want to make clear before I read you the tweet that I posted
is that I am against deplatforming. I don't like uh YouTube coming
in and just banning people. I didn't like it when they banned
Leafy for posting multiple videos on Pokimane. Uh I definitely
wouldn't support a ban on More Pegasar getting his channel removed
for his uh last eight videos out of nine being straight-up slop
and misinformation about Hasan. I'm not going to act like there's
never anything that you can cover about Hasan, but A, it's crazy
to cover the same subject eight times out of your last nine videos.
And B, if you're going to cover the guy, don't be spreading misinformation
about the subject. Now, I am not interested in watching eight
videos on Hasan, so I
Dude, it's it's really funny.
I wish I wish somebody would done like the scan of his cuz it's
not just eight of the last nine. It's going to be like
of the last 300
unironically. the second most recent one. And the amount of details
that we decide to leave out of the complicated nature of Cuba
and its relationship with the West and the fact that there are
blockades that don't allow for oil to come into the country.
Let's just start the video and dissect it as we go. >> If
you remember, he was calling Cubans gross and telling >> Oh,
yes. Hasan calling Cubans gross when he quote tweeted a tweet
about Camila Cabello giving her take on the Cuban government
during I don't know if I saw it out about this one enough. This
one is was particularly annoying, too. I might have missed this
one when we covered the video, okay?
Yeah, that's that's certainly that's Hasan. Surely that's Hasan
calling all Cubans gross. a time in which uh I don't know if
you guys know, that was when the blockade happened. That was
when oil was no longer allowed into Cuba. You don't have to be
a communist to acknowledge that this is more complicated than
Hasanabi
calling all Cubans gross. I wasn't aware that all Cubans had
a multi-million dollar record deal with Interscope. >> Tell
them about their country. Well, now he's You can't have a difference
of opinion and call someone gross. Dude, what what do you think
your career is? You upload videos every day about the same guy.
He's gone to Cuba in the worst way possible. Here we Okay, he's
gone to Cuba in the worst way possible. It's so funny listening
to it a second time. He's gone to CUBA IN THE WORST way
Can I Should I start doing the um the
PewDiePie voice? He's done it in the worst way possible. He's
done it in the worst way possible. I feel like I could imitate
this guy's voice, okay? I feel like that PewDiePie voice is not
hard for people to >> Can we define that? Can we describe
what that even means? You've got an American going to an island,
okay? I know of other Americans that have gone to other islands
and have done way worse things. >> Here we got a tweet.
Tone-deaf radicals flock in It's a It's a PewDiePie voice. It's
the voice PewDiePie used to do when he's like mocking people.
into Havana staying in five-star hotels while the island is in
crisis, a mockery of Cuban people. Oh, good. I'm glad we got
the New York Post's opinion. I wonder who owns the New York Post
and what political leanings they might have.
>> WAIT. CHLEPE, NO! CHLEPE, DON'T GO TO RUPERT MURDOCH'S
EARLY LIFE ARTICLE. THAT'S THE WAY YOU LOSE YOUR YOUTUBE ACCOUNT.
CHLEPE, STOP!
CHLEPE, WHOA! WHOA!
WHOA! What other companies they might own, you know? Uh maybe
Fox News. And we just got Diddy [__] there having
a Yes, Diddy I actually don't think Rupert Rupert Murdoch is
a huge Zionist. I actually don't think he's So, funny enough.
Am I Am I crazy? Do I have to look it up now? I don't think he
is. I think he's just a massive Zionist. >> Diddy [__]
Diddy [__] Why are we calling him Diddy [__]
again? Does anyone even know? I mean, if we're just if we're
just saying things >> Australian, yeah, yeah, okay, okay,
got call people Diddy and alluding to them, you know, being with
minors. Between these two, which one looks more likely to touch
a kid? Between between this one right here on the right and this
right here. I I have I have my own suspicions. >> a great
time. Viewers responded the irony of protesting apartheid and
then directly apartheid apartheid, yes, yes, very literate. Very
well done, More Pegasar. Make another Hasan video.
>> Maybe it was just a mistake. He has a a second opportunity
to say apartheid. Let's see if he can figure that out. in the
tourism apartheid No, no, apartheid apartheid is illiterate.
Here, Pegasus, if you're watching, listen, listen, listen. apartheid
All right, you got it? apartheid Boom. You Next time, next >> Traveling
to villages made for the Western elite that falsely portray the
magic of communism while the real Cubans, barred from that luxury,
suffer its reality. And yeah, we got their whole squad snakes
on a plane come >> Suffer its reality or suffer or suffer
blockades, suffer embargoes, things that are put on them by the
American I think So, I caught a little bit of this video. I think
Queenan was reviewing it earlier today. I think I watched a little
bit of it and
with uh it's like it's a little brutal because I think he misses
the most important part here. He's right. You go to cover the
oil. He might have and maybe I'm making it up. I think he might
have missed More Pegasar skipping the line about the blockade.
>> government. One of Cuba's biggest industries for decades
has been tourism. Guess what Americans are not allowed to do
right now. Half the reason they're even calling this a humanitarian
trip is so that they can go to Cuba. Again, like I let me be
so clear. I'm not some big commie. I'm not like, oh, I love Castro.
But dude, America with everyone's and then some conservative
grift YouTuber is out here like, I can't believe what the communists
are doing. Commies take food and meds to victims of communism.
Right here we have the article. They're staying in luxury hotels
and traveling in air-conditioned buses as the rest of the island
grapples with the The air-conditioned buses. We can't allow for
the air-conditioned
>> the worsening economic crisis that starved it of ill
By the way, the air conditioning on an on a on a bus is just
working off of the generator, right? Like Sorry, the like the
alternator, like the electrical system in the vehicle. If the
vehicle's running, it can power that thing, right? It's not even
a good point, anyway. Like you'd probably just be mad about the
diesel or whatever fuel it would take to run the bus, but electricity,
food, water, and medicine. If that's basically giving away that
there's footage I haven't seen where they're on a closed air
bus. Like where they're on a closed bus somewhere going somewhere.
I still haven't seen that. It's all open air buses that don't
have air conditioning. The News of America convoy sent socialists
from North America and Europe to Cuba by air, sea, and land under
the guise of handing out 20 tons of humanitarian aid while nearly
the entire country is suffering from power outages lasting over
20 hours. The left is welcomed with air conditioning and wasteful
electricity consumption.
Why is that? Why is it that they don't have electricity? Why
is it that they don't have gas? What What is causing all of this?
100 homes What is causing all of it? Well, it's funny you say
that, okay? Cuz if you look right here on the line that he is
not reading in the
Given the visuals from the online blackout this week in the embattled
communist nation of some 11 million PEOPLE AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN JANUARY threatened tariffs on any nation selling it oil.
Why is it that they don't have gas? What What is causing all
of this? 100 homes wouldn't be without power. How could he know?
How could How could more Pegasus possibly know what is causing
this? It
And it's like, why did they leave it out of the Oh, they didn't
leave it out of the Oh, they today if the Castro regime didn't
spend on communist propaganda with the international left. This
is 100 homes wouldn't be without power. How many homes would
be powered if there wasn't a blockade by the United States? I'm
so curious. Oh, what what How many more homes could we power?
I mean, this this Pegasus guy, he he seems to care about homes
being powered. Like it's so funny. This guy is trying to push
all of this blame and all of this Wow, look at Hasan. Hasan and
his friends are the reason why Cubans don't have power in their
house. Like this is exactly what the Cuban government was looking
for. They were By the way, Hasan's friends, the Code Pink
Oh my god, hold on. Let me go find the Code Pink. The The Code
Pink delegation that's taking stuff. One of the One of the groups
that's going. Now, it's not Hasan, and I don't know if Hasan
raised any money for this group, okay?
But I do believe
that they are delivering Hold on. Now, wait, is this uh Oh, the
convoy is delivering. So, it's not necessarily Code Pink. This
is the convoy overall,
Over $500,000
worth of solar panels and generators to support hospitals and
essential infrastructure facing electricity
This line alone
is like already enough to make it worth the trip for everybody.
Right? This line by itself This This line by itself is like everything
you need to understand Oh, they are helping. Oh, it is actually
They are actually They are actually helping. Dude,
every Dude, every single person I see complaining about like
leftists getting people killed cuz the hospital couldn't power
ventilators. Every single person I
making this point, I like I just berate them. I'M LIKE, "ADMIT
ADMIT the leftists did a good thing now. Admit it." I go I go
through I like walk through these lines with them. Admit the
leftists did good. Admit this one time the one This one time
the communists did a good thing, okay? Admit it. Show that you're
a real human being. Admit it. Admit it now, okay? The communist
I don't care. I don't care. Hold on. I I saw that point, too.
Oh, Code Pink is actually affiliated with China. I don't care.
I DON'T CARE who's giving the money. By the way, what's the worst
thing you can say about China? They're communist. And I already
said, tell me the ex- Just admit that the communists did a good
thing this one time. This one time
they did a good thing. This was good. This was a good act. These
people together, good act. Stop it. Stop it. All of you, stop
it. Stop trying to take away from it. Stop. It's It's objectively
a good thing, okay? Stop nitpicking at the edges of this trying
to make it bad. It's just a good thing.
It's obviously a good thing. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Back to the truth. >> for
someone like Hasan to come in, spread the word about what's going
on in Cuba, and then you get some low IQ [__] like
this coming out and making a video saying, "It's all Hasan's
fault that they don't have power in Cuba." Are you like What
do you think? There's a disconnect in your brain. And frankly,
this trip has clearly worked. I mean, hundreds of thousands of
people are being exposed to what's going on in Cuba. There is
a blockade. Something that has been out of the news cycle for
weeks is now being picked up, and people are actually talking
about it. >> This is a gigantic mockery of the entire Cuban
people. The left visits Cuba as if it were a party at a zoo,
and they go to admire the mix Cuba is a tourist country, okay?
I'm sorry to break it to you. There's like 11 million people
that live there. It's basically like the Dominican Republic.
Like these types of little countries that have warm weather,
one of the best ways that they make money is having people come
visit. Mexico's the same way. Pretty tough when you can't get
people from the richest country on Earth to visit, like legally.
That sucks. Also, I just want to point out
I We'll get into the hotel thing in a little bit, but I forgot
to point out when I was covering it. Felipe makes a a good point
as well, maybe even a better point, so I won't spoil that. But
I Dude, there's no tourists on the island right now. The island
is literally like like untravelable to unless you're rich as
right? So, why wouldn't they stay in the nicest place when there's
nobody there? Like it's probably discounted massively for them,
right? Why wouldn't you go stay in the nicest
Like everything's empty. There's nobody there. Dominican Republic,
same way. It is no surprise that people want to go and be tourists
there. The issue is that the United States is choking them. You're
not allowed to be a tourist there right now. They're blockading
fuel from getting to the island. And this is trying to convince
you that Hasan is the reason it doesn't have power. Dude, if
Hasan just didn't go to Cuba, 100 people would have the lights
on in their house. makes misery from a Wow. Thank you, Bore Pegasar.
And by the way, 100 people Is that Is that really what they were
complaining about? 100 people without power? 100 homes? That's
like nobody in Havana. That's like one neighborhood. Which is
bad. It sucks, but it's really like 100 people without
That's it?
That's what the article is saying. Uh apparently, 100 people.
That's like nothing. luxury hotel, it is outrageous. And this
is exactly what Hasan [__] tries to do. This is level
of performative activism where Performative activism is when
you participate in a flotilla that is bringing 20 tons of supplies
to a country that is blockaded by the United States, not receiving
fuel, and is starving. Again, you can have your own questions
about other motivations he might have. Oh, he's only doing it
for content. Oh, he's only doing it cuz he supports communism.
At the end of the day, he's participating, and their goal is
to bring 20 tons of humanitarian aid to Cuba. Frankly, I find
it hard to call that performative. He doesn't actually endure
any of the hardships these people are going through, and just
looks at them as like cattle. To what degree can he ever endure
what the people that live there are going through? What is even
the goal of that statement? He needs to go endure to really know
what it feels like. Like at That's what a bunch of people have
been saying. Uh Hasan would have been better off just being like,
"Dude, could you imagine if Hasan had gone and I I know it for
a fact, and nobody will admit it. If Hasan had gone there and
like roughed it with a family, just on like a home stay with
a family or something, they would have all been like, "Look at
how disgusting this guy is, like larping as a poor person. Look
at how gross he is. He could afford anything. He could actually
make this family's life better, but he's going to go and pretend
that he lives in these squalor these squalid conditions. It's
so gross, man. You Dude, I It's uh It's obviously what would
have happened. It's obviously what would have happened. How's
this How's this dude
I don't know. >> Best The comparison that I can draw is
like a journalist who's boots on the ground wearing a helmet
in a war zone. I don't think anyone has ever had a suspicion
that that's what Hasan is doing. Hasan is a streamer, and in
the world of streamers, I think he's doing a pretty exceptional
job at getting himself involved. And by the way, I I totally
believe the idea that Hasan is probably having a good time and
partying on the island. But in any other scenario, this is what
Cuba is made for. Like I I hate to say it. Cuba is and always
will be a tourist destination. And the only reason they don't
have fuel or money right now is because America thinks that if
they can starve Cuba long enough that the people inside will
rise up and cause a regime change. That is it. That is all. Once
again, Uh okay, legit question. Are there real people that watch
this Pegasus guy? Yes, thousands, hundreds of thousands of real
Like is there not at least a guy that does this type of content
who does not sound like a guy gurgling down
I guess not. I don't know. I People like gimmicky voices, so
Listen, people are
I don't know. I He is like the most popular channel doing the
anti-Hasan content right now. Like the most possible like video
essayist doing it. Doing gimmicky voice? I think these voices
you do are very performative and very hurtful.
You should stop doing them now.
You know? Yeah, Western intervention into another region. Is
Pegasus going to offer me his thoughts on Venezuela? Is Is he
going to offer me his thoughts on Iran? Oh, Iran, I can't wait
for them to be walking around in bikinis. It's going to be so
good. The women are going to be so free. gigantic mockery of
the entire Cuban people. The left visits Cuba as if it were a
party at a zoo, and they go to admire the mix misery from a luxury
hotel. It is outrageous. And this is exactly what Hasan [__]
tries to do. This is level of performative activism where he
doesn't actually endure any of the hardships these people are
going through, and just looks at them as like cattle. Like looking
at cattle. He's looking at them like they're cattle. them through
a cage essentially. In fact, the situation is just getting worse.
Just be happy with it. You love to see it. nationwide blackout
in a It's all Hasan's fault. Hasan blacked out Cuba. How How
is he going to twist this? in a week. Let's check on Hasan. Hasan
responds Let's check on Hasan.
Let's Are we not going to engage with how a blackout happened
in Cuba? Why a blackout is happening in Cuba? It is Zero engagement
with that. Yeah, zero engagement with that. So, bro, Dude, it
It sucks, okay? It sucks. Every I just don't want to always say
democracy was a mistake. Democracy doesn't work. But my god,
the average person, man. The average person needs to just do
better. bro. Explains why he's staying in a five-star hotel in
Cuba. Yeah, this is going to be absolutely rich here. I was saying
tourism is the lifeline for the Cuban economy as it stands currently.
As it always stands. I'm just going to go a step further. Currently,
in the past, it will always be like that. It's a tiny island.
There's It's not every nation like that is going to rely on tourism.
The government has very limited resources, and the American government
makes [clears throat] it illegal
for Americans to stay wherever they want when they're in Cuba.
They have to stay in what they've declared as five-star hotels.
Okay, that's a little vague and inaccurate. You're not allowed
to stay in state-sponsored hotels. You cannot stay somewhere
where the Which also I It's possible they are staying in a state-sponsored
hotel, which is funny. >> Cuban government is directly
making money off of your
Like probably I I can see exactly how this happened. If it's
not it's not just outright lying, which I can It's very possible,
okay? 50% chance Assante's outright lying here, okay? But it's
also possible he was told like, "No, this is where we're staying
cuz this is one of the approved places. The American government's
basically making us stay here. Like all the other places are
closed down right now while the blockade's on, so this is the
place we have to stay." It's possible he was told something like
that, and the way he rationalized that in his head was, "Well,
they made us stay here."
stay. I'm telling you all this because like even the five-star
hotels are not like, you know, they're It's not like this what
the American government has declared five-star hotels. But regardless,
in comparison Like that seems like a genuine misunderstanding.
It's what the American government has deemed five-star hotels.
What?
Like right there, that seems like um That seems goofy. That seems
like that couldn't possibly be true, right?
>> on the island. It's It's a Like it's a needed a place
that could >> parity pretty much. And experiencing that
dichotomy is like definitely me up. Definitely. Well, if I were
to ever If I I mean not ever, but like I I hope to come back,
and when I do I'll probably not abide by the American restrictions.
Oh, okay. I see now. How could have I been so stupid? He just
has to stay in five-star hotels, guys. He cannot help it. The
American government is forcing him. They are torturing him, forcing
him to stay in these five-star ho- Okay, couple things. A, I
don't necessarily buy what Assante's saying in terms of the reasoning
for him staying in a five-star hotel. Flip side, I don't think
you need to winge and moan about this guy staying in a five-star
hotel. Would it be okay if it was a four-star hotel? Does it
need to be three stars? Like what what's the what's the limit
here? Okay, I see now. How could have I been so stupid? He just
has to stay Like no disrespect, this this hotel lobby is like
a totally normal standard-looking hotel lobby. Like I don't even
know why this is being showcased. As we highlighted earlier in
this video, the New York Post I mean
>> I I'll be real, it looks a lot better than a lot of
the rest of the surrounding decor, okay?
Like comparatively,
it's really really nice.
So, Assante's not great. Dude. Post is always going to be very
um negative towards the leftist sentiment. And so obviously,
they're also pushing champagne socialists in Cuba stage concert,
stay in five-star hotel as country plunges into nationwide blackout.
This five-star Dude, um these people do I Man, I do wish that
these people could just be honest sometimes cuz now I've started
to get on the other side of the concert thing again.
I've They're speaking very specifically about the concert.
And to me, it's like you you're giving something away that people
could come back at you with.
So if you don't know the story about the concert, the concert
that they go to that the apparently power goes out because of
the the knee cap band came out and said their manager came out
and said, "Well, actually it was a community concert that was
free for everybody, and and like we just played like a little
bit. It wasn't meant We weren't even meant to play. It was just
meant to be local bands." And then I'm like, "Okay, hold on,
Zortician. Then this is what I needed to know. It was part of
a spring festival that was already planned. If that's the case,
then awesome. Then they're totally off the hook." Cuz the way
they were saying They weren't saying who organized it. They were
just saying it was like free for Cubans, and it was mostly Cubans
attending. And I'm like, "Okay, so you put on a concert for free?
Like you you brought the equipment or something? But no, if they
If it was already planned and it was already set up, then yeah,
I don't everybody
Bringing that up was
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, every Then I'm totally fine. Cuz the way
they were talking about who scheduled it, who like actually set
it up, I was like, "Oh, do they not know what's going on there?"
Like or did they set it up themselves? If they're as long as
they're not lying about it, thank god. Never mind. I would get
back all that back. They're not lying about it. Oof. Thank god.
Cuz I It seemed to me like they were talking around it in a weird
way, like who organized it? They weren't saying it. And that
that felt very weird to me,
Anyway, we're good. We're hotel costs
to a night. Like I'm sorry. Like that's like a three-star hotel
here in Canada. Unless someone can prove to me that Assante's
staying in this hotel for free, I I don't want to hear it. If
anything, it's probably a good thing that he's staying in an
expensive hotel, spending a lot of money in Cuba. in five-star
hotels, guys. He cannot help it. The American government is forcing
him. They are torturing him, forcing him to stay in these five-
Like frankly, I just think it was a dumb point by Assante. But
I also don't think it's a point that he should even have to answer
for. Five-star hotels? No.
He would never pick a five-star hotel out of his own volition.
He's not in He's not known to indulge in any sort of luxury at
all, right? He's not known to have, you know, Gucci bags, live
in a mansion on his own in Hollywood, or buy supercars. He never
does that. Nor does he ever go on luxury trips or paid propaganda
trips. You know what Assante actually wanted to do? Why do these
people keep calling that a paid propaganda trip?
Either Assante Dude, it doesn't even work with your own talking
points. "Oh, it's a paid prop- No, Assante loves China. Assante
loves China to a totally irrational cringe extent. He adores
China in every possible way. He definitely would pay for all
of that out of his own pocket. He definitely would believe everything
told to him on that tour without question. He loves China.
Why do you think This one was probably state-sponsored in some
way. They were definitely going there at the behest of the Cuban
government, right?
But it's like you don't have to pay Assante to go to China and
get to see China and get to like talk about how awesome communism
is in China. It doesn't even make sense. Isn't Ludwig and Atrioc
in China right now? No idea. I just know Assante loves China.
He's always loved China. Like to a totally crazy extent.
who was to experience Like I'm so tired of these points. I'm
totally fine if you want to say that China was Oh, also, the
five-star room Well, like a Sorry, a room in that five-star hotel,
lowest price $100 a night.
Bro, you can't get a room in America for $100 a night. You can't
get like a like a mo- You'd be lucky if you find a motel room,
okay, for $100 a night in America. Like a two-star hotel room
Sorry, two-star motel room.
was a paid propaganda trip. But like this cringe rightoid woke
scolding regarding, "Oh, you're a communist, but you spend money
on things you like? Don't you know that that like goes against
communism?" Like yes, dude. The The guy lives in LA. Like I'm
What the [__] do you want? experience some of the
suffering, you know? He wanted to suffer like the rest of the
people, but unfortu- No, he did not want to suffer like the rest
of the people. He wanted to deliver aid, take a trip to Cuba,
and spend money in Cuba, okay, while making content. I don't
think he wanted to suffer or endure suffering. I don't think
Assante has ever wanted to suffer a day in his life. What is
this point? >> cannot make this up, bro. This guy unironically
goes, "Oh my god, guys. I have to stay in a five-star hotel."
You absolute champagne socialist
Okay, here's a thought. New one, brand new. Nobody's ever called
him a champagne socialist. >> thought. How about you stop
larping for once in your goddamn life, you damn worm, you pathetic
loser, dude? How total Uh Chill B's not going to let that one
go. "You damn worm. You pathetic loser, bro.
You damn worm. You're a damn worm. You pathetic loser, bro."
Okay, dude. There's no
>> There's no way he lets that go. death is this man? You're
chilling in a five-star hotel while the country is going through
blackouts, and the people are suffering, the strugg- It's so
comical. If If they can prove somehow that Assante did not pay
for his hotel room, or if Assante himself confirms that, okay,
you might have me, okay? I might be like, "What
Why is this guy not paying for his hotel room? If If you're a
multimillionaire,
I'd at least pay for the hotel room you're staying in." five-star
hotel while the country is going through blackouts, and the people
are suffering, struggling to get any sort of resources at all,
and here you are. >> I just don't understand why you would
bring up that they're struggling and they're struggling to get
resources. Like why would you bring that up without mentioning
why that's happening? Why would you bring that up without thinking,
"Okay, well, if they're struggling and they're struggling to
get res- Because he obviously The answer here, by the way, Chill
B keeps asking. The answer is this guy doesn't care about Cuba.
He literally just cares about painting Assante in the worst light
possible. Does not give a [__] about Cuba. Does not
give a [__] about American politics. Does not give
a [__] about essentially anything. He just knows
that he makes money when he says Assante is bad. So that's what
he does. He's just going to figure out how to say Assante is
bad in the in the like basically the minimum distance. He is
an optimization algorithm, okay? The shortest distance to Assante
is bad possible, he will travel that shortest distance, and he
will put a video out, okay? He will do the laziest
lightest amount of work,
and he will immediately put a video out. Hassan is very bad.
Hassan is very bad.
Does it help Cuba more if Hassan sleeps in a tent? I think it's
better optics, but how does that change for Cuba? It It actually
is worse for Cuba, Zizek. You are not feeding the industry there
at all if you stay in a tent.
It actually is literally worse for Cuba. It's like maybe it looks
better for Hassan, yeah. What Hassan should do is he should figure
out [clears throat] the thing that makes like people who hate
him and will try to say he's bad no matter what what will make
them least upset. That's how he should live his life, right?
He should just figure out what upsets those people the very least
and do those things regardless of how much it helps anybody else.
Amazing. That's what more Pegasus wants. Well, it's actually
not what more Pegasus wants cuz then he'd have to do more more
work to figure out how Hassan is bad.
He loves it this way. Sources, why is Hassan going to Cuba? Like
you're out here reading this news, right? You're reading about
the Nuestra America, right? Well, you're You're You're aware
that they're bringing resources to Cuba. Why are they bringing
resources to Cuba? What What is going on in Cuba right now? What
is going on around Cuba? Why are you not mentioning that? We're
6 minutes into this video. You haven't said [__]
about the American blockade. Like I I just don't know I don't
get it. Why are we so hyper-focused on this guy being a champagne
socialist?
You know, you said it yourself. Uh there's hundreds of people
without power, right? Why are you focused on Hassan when you
could be talking about those hundreds of people?
You know what I mean? Why aren't you talking about what America
is doing to cause this? Like you want to talk about, oh, Hassan's
not enduring any of the suffering that these people are dealing
with. Dude, you're out here in Singapore, okay, on the other
side of the planet talking about some guy I think he's Singaporean.
I don't think he lives in Singapore. I
I don't know if Chili Pepe knows this. I So somebody told me
he was Canadian and I had like some reason to believe that. guy
who's actually in Cuba. Talking about some guy who's actually
assisting and bringing the humanitarian aid to Cuba. Who's covering
the story? Who's giving information to the people about the subject?
You're the one who's sensationalizing the story. You're the one
who's getting views. You're the one who is making money off of
the suffering of these people. Like I reiterate, out of your
last nine videos, eight of them are on Hassan. Like is this whole
video just going to boil down to, oh, he's a champagne socialist.
Oh, he likes Gucci. Forget about why he's in Cuba to begin with.
Oh, he's in a five-star hotel. Is that it? We're just going to
nibble around the edges of what's actually going on right now.
>> There is some truth to what he's saying. There is like
some restriction to whatever, but nobody's forcing him to go
there and waste a bunch of resources and forcing him to stay
in five-star hotels. You could just stay in So America, [__]
Some restrictions on where to stay. That's not talking about
the blockade. That's restrictions on where to stay. Dude,
are we serious? Are we dead ass right now? I'll be participating
in this. The US has strangled Cuba since its successful revolution
for the crime of sovereignty and dignity for its people. This
latest example of the heightened blockade seeks to bring Gazan
siege warfare and starvation closer to home. We mustn't look
away. He is clearly a part of the flotilla Nuestra America. Like
the whole point is to bring humanitarian aid to Cuba. You would
If anything, you could argue that it would be more champagne
socialist of him to stay in America as you're implying. Look,
if you want to take issue with Hasanabi supporting the Cuban
regime, that I think that's fine. I think you can totally do
that. I think if you're going to criticize Hassan for his participation
in the flotilla, even if he's not directly on the boat, even
if he's streaming in a air-conditioned hotel room, okay, feel
free to make your critiques of what he's supporting and what
he's doing, but this idea that we're so fixated on his drain
on the Cuban people when again America is doing literally all
of the damage, it's it's just comical. Anyways, I hope you guys
enjoyed We're not going to stop with the No. The We You can criticize
communism.
That's an important part to being, you know, any in any Western
country. You can criticize communism all you like,
Don't tell Don't tell them to stop.
People are totally free to criticize funding the Cuban government
in some way, okay? Totally fine to do that. Sorry, there's a
Snot Nose Swagger tweet. There's a Chronic Sonic tweet from a
couple days ago. Wait, yes, this morning? This morning, okay?
This is a picture from more Pegasus's Instagram. Now, he's like,
whatever. I'm not making fun of him. It looks like he's in the
gym or something. Good for him, okay? But why he got to hit us
with the cash stare? Why he got to hit Why he got to hit us with
the [__] cash stare?
What What is that?
It's actually so crazy. Wait, he's doing the cash stare. Also,
a couple people pointed out a couple people pointed out Oh, where
Where is this guy wearing his
He's wearing his watch
like 4 in up his forearm. Why the [__] are you wearing
your watch like halfway up your forearm?
Brother, that's not where a watch goes. A watch is for your wrist.
It's a wrist watch. It's not a middle of the forearm
What the [__] are you doing? How By the way, how
tight and how little muscle mass must there be there that your
watch stays like that?
How the
How the [__] does your watch stay like that? I I
know I've sometimes tried to put my watch further up on my arm
when I'm like lifting weights or something. It slides back down
to my wrist.
How in the world do you get your watch to stick there? What's
going on? That's That's weird, okay?
That's some weird stuff. I think we got to zoom in on the watch
here. Dude.
I We can probably go deeper. This This is the Casio watch that
every like Reddit post tells you is like the entry-level watch,
right? Digital watches. I feel like this is a Dude, I don't want
to get too I don't want to get too far into it, but this is like
a Reddit watch, okay? This is like you Google, hey, I want to
get a watch to look kind of cool and what watch should I get?
And every single Reddit post tells you to get this Casio watch.